But what does the veil being torn into
two
convey? Now I can get rid of the King
James right
here. What does that
convey? What does heaven being opened to
Jesus convey?
Meaning now heaven is open and the
spirit comes from the father out of
heaven upon Christ to now work with
Christ.
Well, what does the veil being torn
apart convey? Well, very easy. Let me
explain. The there were two veils. The
veil that you had to go through for the
holy place where they the priests would
serve and then the second
veil
that covered the most holy place. Let me
give you a little background. You
ready? You guys ready for a little
background?
in the tabernacle and then the temple,
you had two veils. The outer veil that
you'd have to enter into the holy place
where the priest would serve
daily. But then you had a second veil.
Behind the second veil was the mercy
seat, the ark of the covenant. And only
the high priest could enter once a year
on
kipurim. Leviticus 16 only once a
year because you could not enter the
most holy place because God's presence
was there in a miraculous fashion and
you could only enter being absolutely
pure,
unblenmished. God was showing them how
serious it is to be in God's visible
presence while in sin. You'd be struck
dead.
So God in his
mercy, God in his
mercy veiled himself so that you would
not be consumed by his
holiness. So when
the veil that covered the ark of the
covenant was torn, notice from top to
bottom. You know how thick the veil was.
And not only that, to do it from top to
bottom means this was a divine work
because if humans tore it, they would
start from the bottom
up, right? This was a sign. God tore it.
Well, what did that
mean? You understand now the meaning of
it? Do you guys understand the meaning
of it? It meant two things.
There's no longer a veil between you and
God if you come to him through Christ.
Christ has now removed the veil
separating you from God because now he
gives you direct access to God through
him in union with him by his blood by
confession. That's number one. Okay, you
with me there? You want me to show you
what it means?
Number two, it means God no longer
dwells in the temple. Therefore, his
presence does not need to be veiled
because he's no longer there. Now that
Christ died, he now abandons and rejects
the temple. So there is no reason to
veil the most holy place because God is
not there anymore.
He abandoned the temple because now it's
only in Christ you will meet God and
have access to God. Can you with me
there? Let me show it again now from
scripture so you don't think I'm
lying. You know again I thank you guys.
You know why? Though I know this stuff,
I don't get the opportunity to share it.
Why? Because how many people are going
to invite me to talk about these topics?
So there's stuff I know that I don't
share because I don't have an
opportunity. So Lord, bless you guys for
being willing to put up with me in my
darkest moments and pray for my healing.
And thank you for PayPal Patriot
supporters. God bless you guys. If it
wasn't for you, I can't do
this. There's a lot more I can share,
but I need to have opportunity to do it.
Pray for that support because I've lost
a few. But le life is life. Now watch
here. You want me to prove to you that
this is what it means? All right,
because I know you how you guys are. You
know, you know how you are. All
right. I know how you are. But you know
how you are. Let me repeat what this
means. When the veil was torn from top
to bottom after Christ
died, that
means God's presence is no longer
veiled. You can now have direct access
to God through Christ because now he's
separated that divide. But secondly,
secondly, it meant that God no longer
dwells in the temple. So you don't need
to veil his presence because by
rejecting Christ, he rejected the
temple. He's not there
anymore. And how do I know this is what
it means here? Hebrews 4 14- 16.
Therefore, since we have a great high
priest who has ascended into heaven,
Jesus son of God, let us hold firmly to
the faith we profess. For we do not have
a high priest who's unable to empathize
with our weaknesses because he became
human to experience the full orb of
human life and existence. Pun intended.
You hear that, Jay? Full
orb. Them orbs
again. Let us hold firmly to the faith
we
profess. Yeah, I love that movie. That
was my favorite Jesus of Nazareth film
of all the Jesus movies. This is my
favorite. All right, now watch
here.
Firmly, right? But we have one who has
been tempted every just as we are. Yet
he did not sin. Now look, let us then
approach God's throne, mercy seat, cuz
there you won't find wrath consuming you
for your sin. You'll find grace and
favor. And approach it boldly without
fear. Don't be afraid like the high
priest so that we may receive mercy and
find grace to help us in our time of
need. See what the meaning is?
See what the meaning
is. How do we now access the most holy
place? Through the flesh of Jesus
Christ, being united to him, covered by
his blood and
confession. His flesh is the curtain.
When his flesh was broken, that meant
the veil that separated you and God was
broken. You see how deep the death of
our Lord
is when his flesh body was broken. That
flesh being broken meant now God's
presence is no longer veiled because the
veil is open for you to have access to
it. Where am I getting this from? Here
you go. Hebrews 6 19 and 20.
We have this hope as an anchor for the
soul firm and secure. It enters the
inner sanctuary behind the curtain where
our
forerunner Jesus has entered on our
behalf. He went ahead of us to now bring
us into the most holy place and give us
unmuted access to God. He has become a
high priest forever in the order of
Melzdc. Now
watch. Let me show you
again. Oh, sorry. I forgot. Hebrews
10:19-22. Here about here it is. Hebrews
19-22. Watch here. Look how deep.
Because remember how deep you want me to
go? You want me to go deeper? All right.
I'm going to have to go deeper. All
right.
Because why does his flesh being
broken point to and how does it point to
the veil being broken that hides God's
presence from us? So now you have
unmuted access to God because I'm going
to show you something else. I'm going to
show you something else. You
ready? You ready? Sorry, I got to go off
camera. So don't don't be upset at me.
You're amazing. This is what happens
when I have to chase the cat, take him
into the
bathroom and do stuff for him. All
right,
guys. Therefore, brothers and sisters,
since we have confidence, tend to the
most holy place
by the blood of Jesus. Why? By a new and
living way, open for us through the
curtain that is his
body. Let me see if Let me get a better
translation. Hold on. Sometimes they
translate not as good. Hold on.
Sometimes I don't trust the NIV.
Sometimes it's
good. Watch the
connection. That is his flesh. You see,
there are two words in Greek. One
s one soma that means body. The other
sarks which means flesh. Therefore,
brothers, since we have confidence to
enter the holy places by the blood of
Jesus, by a new and living way, which he
inaugurated for us through the veil,
that is his flesh. Now, look how deep
the Bible is. Why is his flesh called
the
veil? And this is going to tie with our
holy mother. Since we have a great
priest over the house of God, let us
draw near with a sincere heart and full
assurance of faith, having our hearts
sprinkled from an evil conscience, and
our bodies washed with pure water.
There's your
baptism. Water
baptism. But why is his flesh called the
veil? And how do we enter through that
veil? His flesh. because his flesh was
broken, meaning the veil was torn apart.
And by his death, he now assures you
your sins are covered and you can enter
God's presence. Now, but why is the
flesh likened to a veil? All right. Did
you think we'd go? And by the way, I
didn't even know we're going to go this
deep. Honestly, I don't have a
script. I don't script these talks. I
don't. Why? How you doing, brother? Love
you, man. See, now here's a brother,
right? He's Eastern Orthodox, serving
Orthodox. He's a good man, loves me,
prays for me, and he's faithful to his
church. He doesn't believe outside
Eastern Orthodox Church there's
salvation, but he leaves that to God,
and he prays, and he's not a jerk. And I
love this brother. I met him and his
family. So, he's a good brother. I love
you, man. So, now watch here. Why is his
flesh the veil? Here you go. Let me get
you the
link. Watch here. Why is the flesh of
our Lord called the veil? Here's
why the word
dwelt. And the word became flesh. Flesh
became dwelt. Guys, this is where you're
going to see the holy theotocos being
the ark of the covenant. The word
[Applause]
eskosen. Guess what it means? To pitch
your tent
tabernacle. So what it's saying is Jesus
is the God who came to live in a temple,
a tabernacle of flesh, a physical body
of flesh.
right here to dwell tabernacle to pitch
a tent. I dwell as in a tent and camp
have my tabernacle from skina meaning
tent or tabernacle. The Hebrew
equivalent often associated with sko is
shakan which means to dwell or reside
particularly in reference to God's
presence in the tabernacle temple. And
by the way you Greek Greek readers of
the septigent if you read Exodus 33 7-11
Exodus 40 34-38 in the Greek it says
that when they pitched the skina of
meaning the tab of meaning God filled it
with his
glory Exodus 40 34 38 and if you want
I'll even show you the Greek when he
appeared in a cloud and descended upon
it. That's exactly John 1:14. The word
became
flesh and pitched his temple among us.
We beheld his
glory. It's the same Greek words, glory,
tabernacle, glory, tabernacle. So John
knows his Bible and he assumes you know
the Bible. So when he says when Christ
became flesh became man that physical
body was the
tabernacle and that's when we beheld his
glory. Same words of Exodus